the rest of the cast they all had a
script but they had to roll with
whatever i provided and um they were
amazing man they were absolutely
incredible but there was one moment like
generally the the entire thing was set
up our director amazing director french
director called christian carrion who uh
he designed this whole thing to kind of
preserve
the the first take so the first take
would happen and whatever i did it was
all designed about making that as real
and as natural and truthful as possible
and um
generally we would get the first take
and he were like he's beautiful it is
absolutely uh
he was clearly from wales and
nine times out of ten we'd do the first
take and move on and i would just
organically know where i had to go for
the next scene i'd need to drive
somewhere or and the camera would be in
the car watching me drive there the
whole way um but this one time there was
i'm running down this like um this alley
not an alley it's like a pathway in a
mountain in the highlands of scotland
and this car comes out of nowhere and
absolutely cacked my pants right and um
and i decided that because there was
potentially malevolent forces at work
here i should hide so i decided that
what i would do is i jumped into the
bushes and i climbed up a tree i mean i
climbed up a scene right
i was like here
i went high
right and then i'm at the top of this
tree thinking like oh i actually did
this i'm 42 and i did this and uh i just
yeah good and uh it's our friendship to
go like come down james and i come back
then he goes i need you to do it again i
need to go down this way and i go like
oh but i thought maybe you know the bad
guys are coming and you go up the tree
goes like yeah
how do i say in english it's just a bit
um
stupid
all right
i'd like you to go run this way
[Applause]
[Music]